for Bo nickel nothing changes for him
nothing changes for him they still have
to have him on this aggressive path to
get to a contender so I don't think
they're gonna give him another guy of
Jamie Pickett's caliber his next fight's
gonna be guy on a winning streak I would
assume you know Bo Nick at this point
there are there have been no chinks in
his armor besides a gas force in that
head arm choke could have stepped off to
side control you know there's not a lot
to hate on the guy for so I think they
give him knacks a guy who's maybe on a
two fight winning streak maybe three
fight win streak definitely has to be
coming off at least one win so then
that's the next step and then you know
he's two or three fights away from being
right in those top dogs there so he's
gonna be a tough founding for anybody
anybody in the top 15